yeah welcome to this video playing
international was the M Western I'd to
check that right it's it's not like his
cold that's his name I mean okay um so
Queens gambit the route goes in yeah is
that incredibly popular nowadays started
on the type level and snow like
trickling down to to the to the M yeah
to the to the lower levels let's say so
okay this line it's a simple line for
wide that requires um no particular
knowledge and never really looked at
this opening um in any reasonable detail
so I'm playing this to make sure that
i'm not totally outwitted the first
couple of moves hmm that's uncommon I
mean I mean normally they play a six I
believe to prevent this move so I'm
going to go for that and take his bishop
pal okay so this is this is certainly
comfortable for white a little bit
better i think for what um so how am I
going to play here interesting i wonder
if Bishop g4 is a move that helps him
probably it is so I'm trying to play
Knight be 32 c 5 and avoid the trade of
the bishops okay so he's up form i
discover
attack hmmmmm interesting i wonder if
Queen a3 as a move here it's a very
unconventional solution I could be
interesting could be interesting that
more let's try that if he takes of the a
file is opened so Luke a b1 is a
possibility and I'm pretty quick with
Bishop f3 and 93 to c5 as an interesting
try if he takes I mean he does not have
to you can even contemplate a move like
night to before remember that's a
strange move I don't believe in that one
okay so he actually allows me to take oh
yeah I'm going to do that so and let's
see i mean the pawn structure is just
comfortable here now for me so i have a
have a bit of a hard time to believe in
this concept um so f for em i guess a
form and to block his F Holmes the king
of to wear so one camp it's a bit slow
ish but anyway don't think he has any
particularly great continuation so how
to play that now night over to see three
or where am I supposed to go Oh Bishop
f3 mmm but sugar three night before
maybe when night only to has to be
relocated again I'm going to see 3 i'm
not i'm not really sure about it
it's a bit slower yeah trade trade one
looks or not one book or not the gunite
III might double oh ok i mean i'm not
i'm not really a claiming a huge
advantage he or anything but it looks it
looks comfortable here's some somewhat
tied to his his porn weaknesses so how
am I going to continue I probably have
to trade rooks hmm hmm maybe trading
looks this kind of it's a bit wimpish I
mean wimpish is the one right here it's
a bit term well it's not quite clear
ever have enough left to try to play for
win but I'm going to play with that with
92 b5 was I'm not sure about that move
to do weakens a bit so how am I going to
play this is actually ok night to see
one or not ok
I wondered if the night is some maybe
not that bad on d3
I think it p probably should go G for
here in this position preventing me from
taking and going age four
okay maybe I should have taken any gonna
age so i'm not sure about it Wow
I can't even go bishop do you 12 a for
now it's a very quite unconventional way
to play this here
some nights you want to be three and
then what exactly ok many hasn't a nice
choice I can also take c6 take g5 and
play it charges it also very nice but
does it winner not sure about that if I
go night see one here has might be aid
not totally sure if that wins time
warning I might have not see one king in
793 night XD form okay let's let's do
this this is also very nice what's one
of the good continuations it was bit
difficult to to choose because it all is
very nice he doesn't have 97 that before
setup was quite weird weakening the
position even more
so got a nice night ending here how to
window it's very nice but hard to win
Knight to c4 would be good to get in I
mean he cannot really move this night he
can but okay
be 595 jack black residents yeah that
was I was a YC resigning actually I mean
I was just when I was thinking how am i
winning here I mean I was just
automatically going to the king and porn
endgame but I was really harm i winning
yeah yeah okay a king g6 of course he I
just have had this one no kingi 50 I'm
really rusty a king air for the reacting
here for just wins the pawn of course
yeah okay so King here and this is a
draw according to the engine nice mmm so
Knight e5 was a big mistake actually ha
wow wow wow so just any other movies
winning of course yeah well the night
and game with an extra bonus is just a
win like here something like that for
example here and night coming not coming
down Wow but ok let's let's look at this
end near ending I mean this is kind of
fascinating so King f3 is going king g5
that's the problem and i have no move if
I move this point forward he just going
to catch it and I don't have anything
anything to show for that amazing yeah
this is just that's just bad right he
only has to make sure that whenever i go
here he has king g5 so he cannot go King
g5 himself yeah I like this and king of
3 is going to win it i'm getting getting
them ok so let's review the whole game
briefly yeah i think it is a mistake
here to to allow night to be five i
think just a success how they normally
go about that and then go to d6 i have
seen games with that idea yeah so yeah I
got the bishops is 6 yeah and now this
9280 I think that's not bad am Bishop g4
was was an option be sure oops d 7 yeah
I now queen e 03 that's an interesting
idea actually it was briefly such a
stock which top move interesting i think
it's it's it's it's this kind of
position is interesting i have the B
file I control before so I cannot go
here or anything and I have this idea
yeah like night be 32 c 5 also bishop f3
this is kind of nice Luke c8 is what the
engine is giving and now the question is
how to precisely play um
a phone might be 3 i'd be 397 oh that's
okay probably for him i mean i'm not
claiming that a much better here but
it's a it's an interesting way to play
maybe a form that that's what the engine
suggests to have a 5 whenever the night
moves it gives 0.4 mm I don't know yeah
I'd rather be why Jim but it's nothing
particularly great yeah this is
surprising really f5 computer doesn't
like the captured wants to go Bishop f3
okay it makes some sense I'd actually
threatens Queen d6 Bishop g5 so yeah
okay how does he protect d5 probably
like this and then I can still take if I
want no but can it cannot be really a
bad decision to take I mean why should
always be a little bit better than this
in the situation just a bit Cain I'd be
one also also then Jan move ok ok with
the comp what does the Compton it wants
to play Knight c3 and keep material on
the board yeah maybe that's better I'm
really not sure but I like this simple
approach it just gives them it gives me
a slightly better position yeah so I
mean you can analyze this of course as I
said there were a couple of moments like
hear ya stockfish ok stop which gives
the idea this was an all way there was
always an interesting option around this
this point to to gain some some space on
the Kings at getting the f4 square in
particular where night might be very
handy and so on it was an interesting
alternative and I thought he could have
could have played maybe that move just
strictly shutting down everything
and maybe like a night up to if not to
deform it to like here to have six
having 94 as an option I mean here this
is quite closed I think he has good
chance simply hold that nothing nothing
much happening but what was really quite
surprising most that he went before
after that I think I'm just winning
should just win the game yeah the
compass jumps to one point something
with multiple ideas yeah this is one of
them it just Ricans the whole the whole
Queen side a lot and this is the best
continuation according to the calm so I
can be going to satisfy him yeah winning
the pawn and we get a get a night end
game which is some quite relatively
relatively easy to win um even though
I'm I screwed screwed things up a little
bit yeah it's 95 I'll do the Buddhist
sir checked too nicely put I mean this
was this was much easier for example
winning another pawn yeah i was i was
really only thinking okay night to trade
and then that's it but of course you
have to do every King and porn endgame
separately and many many unique features
so here it was a draw or would have been
a draw okay thanks for watching